it's help to buy scheme I really think
it's helped to sell to help to sell
scheme I don't even think it was created
to really truly bring financial
independence to first-time buyers hey
what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I wanted to give my
thoughts and really explain what the
help to buy government scheme is what
it's about and whether I think it's a
good idea whether you should do it or
not so firstly what is the help to buy
government scheme
okay so there's different types of help
to buy schemes there's help to buy Isis
there's help to buy with the mortgage
with the proper generally speaking this
is one of those and I'm summarizing a
little bit it's when the government will
lend you they'll give you a load and
it's usually interest-free four or five
years and this loan helps you with your
deposit when you're buying a property so
instead of having to put down maybe
twenty percent they'll give you the vast
bulk of the deposit you'll only put down
five percent and then the mortgage will
then top up the rest of the difference
for the purchase price so what it means
is it means that you can buy a house
with very very little money now whilst
that's great and if you're looking to
buy a house and you haven't got much
money if you're like oh my gosh I need
to buy a house that I want to live in
and I'm a first-time buyer and I really
haven't got that much money I guess to
help to buy scheme could help you it
could be good the problem with it is and
this is the problem whenever the
government help you there's always an
agenda and there's always strings
attached so with the help to buy scheme
firstly they're not helping you to buy
it by giving you money okay all they're
doing is they're just loaning you money
so you still need to pay that money back
and if you don't when you sell the house
you need to the government will have a
stake in that house so and it's interest
free but it's only interest free for a
fixed period of time so really it's not
much different from just having a really
high mortgage you so that whilst they're
helping you I guess get on the ladder I
think that's the first thing to bear in
mind second thing to bear in mind is
it's you can't buy a house and then rent
it out so there's a lot of restrictions
involved in fact you can't just buy any
house
you have to live there you have to buy a
house of a particular price
generally speaking depends on where it
is in the UK it needs to be under six
hundred thousand pounds which is if it
still gives you a quite a lot of room to
buy the kind of house that you'd
probably want to buy anyway but I think
the biggest problem is often with these
help to buy schemes is the house you
need to buy it needs to be a new build
so it needs to be a brand new house it's
not just a case of what house do we want
to move into this one's really nice
there's no you they forced you down a
particular Avenue so buying a new build
house to live in
it's just not smart it's not smart in my
opinion because if you buy a brand-new
house it's good when you buy a brand-new
house usually the value drop
straightaway so you're buying a house
that the value is probably likely to
drop your very highly leveraged on the
house because you've borrowed from the
bank and now you've all you've done is
borrowed from the government so you're
gonna be negative equity potentially
very quickly meaning that the value of
the house is lower than the debt on the
house so that's not good and not only
that but the house because you've got to
live in it you can't rent it out it's
not going to even make you any money so
that kind of a house is going to be a
liability you're gonna have a lot of
debt that comes with it so whilst it's
attractive that the government are going
to give you the money and you're going
to only have to be able to put down a
small but that was that's most that's an
attractive offer I think it's a really
you know there's a lot of strings
attached and I'd be really careful about
doing that and the kind of people that
are attracted to a help to buy type
scheme are people that are struggling
financially generally speaking because
they're first-time buyers they haven't
got much money for a deposit so what's
happening is people that are struggling
for money are being encouraged to take
on more debt but not good debt okay I'm
all for taking on good debt as an
investment but bad debt and then getting
into negative equity and you know what I
don't want to be too controversial
because I already saying
controversial things and the government
probably not probably they don't like my
message my message of financial freedom
and investments the government aren't a
fan of that because their message is go
to school get good grades study hard
then go to university and get government
debt right then leave University and get
a good job for life then be a good boy
in the office until you 67 years old and
then retire on 40% of what you couldn't
afford to live on in the first place
after working 40 years for 40 hours a
week and and and that's that's the
message you know that's what we're told
to do and I feel like the help to buy
scheme is gonna it's gonna make that
happen even more so because people are
going to end up getting into the rat
race and getting into debt and and
having a property that they live in
I wouldn't even recommend getting a
property that you live in I'd recommend
just the little money that you've got
okay
just rent somewhere and then use that
little money that you've got to try and
get some investments or invest it in
yourself like so for me not a fan of the
helped by escape even the helped by Isis
you know all the government are doing
these help to my daughter's isn't it
fantastic isn't it great if you keep
saving saving saving saving saving then
they've government will give you a bonus
but that's what they want they want you
to save save save save save then you do
what with the money you put the money in
the nicer in the bank but that's a bad
plan because rich people don't save save
save save save what rich people do is
they let money flow through them and
they invest invest invest because again
it's what we're told to do and I hate to
sound like a conspiracist and this video
might even be taken down by YouTube
because this is them this is not the
kind of message that the system wants
but I don't care a man
because I'll tell you something the
system wants you to be poor you go to a
bank and you ask for a loan of twenty
thousand pounds and you tell them you
want to invest the in property okay and
they're gonna say that's too risky but
you tell them you want to invest it on a
holiday or on a wedding and now say no
problem
so why is that why will the bank not
give you money to invest in the property
because it's too risky but then now
happily give you the money to go on a
holiday what to get married I tell you
why it's because the system want you to
be in debt and want you to be a slave
and want you to be stuck in the rat race
and being charged you might not be
charged from the government for five or
five years but then suddenly you've got
interest to pay right so for me I can't
I feel like I can just sell obvious that
it was trying to happen in I want to say
it's a scam but I'll tell you something
the whole system is set up so that
you're poor that's that's that's how
it's set up
and ultimately as well okay because
George Osborne announced help to buy in
2013 to help the first-time buyers I
just don't believe that I don't believe
it's to help the first-time buyers do
you know what it's actually for is to
help it's always to help the rich is to
help the developers as a developer I
love I can't benefit from how to buy
skews okay I can't benefit from it
because I'm not a first-time buyer I'm
not wanting to buy a new build house to
live in I'm not it don't tick the box I
can't benefit from it but I actually can
benefit from it because I'm a house
builder I buy land and build houses and
sell the new build houses off the
scratch sorry I buy land build houses
and then I sell the houses off so from
my perspective as a property developer
the help to buy scheme is fantastic why
because it means that when I build these
new houses I can flog them easier
because people like you maybe are
watching the video I don't know I'll
help these people that mean help by the
government they can afford to buy my
house is at a premium rate and the
government back them so actually it's
called it helped him its help to buy
scheme I really think it's helped to
sell to help to sell scheme and I don't
even think I don't even think it was
created to really truly bring financial
independence to first-time buyers I
think it's just it's just it
it's to help developers is to help the
seller and all of these things is same
as when George Osborne brought in
section 24 2016 that was when it was
announced phased into 2020 what's that
done everyone said oh he said it's to
help the tenants is to help first-time
buy stuff but it hasn't because all it
does is it's just pushed up ranks so
rents have gone up and section 24
doesn't even apply for companies the
changes are also you could be buying a
company and it doesn't affect you so
it's like is this really to help the
tenants and the first-time buyers
section 24 made me very wealthy I'm very
happy about section 24 help to buy skin
very happy about it but I'm advising you
watching this video because you've
probably seen the title and you're
thinking of getting the government to
help you and get in an ISO and saving up
money that when you save up money and
put it in the bank which is what we're
told to do by the media and the
government and the education system it's
all part of the same ran by the elite
super-rich and guess what the super-rich
don't want you to have financial
independence because the super-rich they
want for the wealth okay so when you're
told by the system and the TV in the
media and the government and school to
save up money and put it in the bank
because that's safe number one the money
in the bank shrinks because of cost of
inflation so it's actually a stupid
thing to do but what do you think the
bank do with your money they invest in
property so they tell you one thing and
they do another thing they tell you
invest in the bank because it's safe but
then you give all the money I taste
something if tomorrow we all said to the
banks can we have that money please they
want now to give it to us because
they've invested it all in property the
very thing that they don't let us do
because they tell us it's too risky so
as I said controversial video I expect
this to video to get a lot of hate
I expect this video even potentially to
be taken down but the system wants you
poor the media the super-rich the elite
the government the banks even the
education system like the education
system themself the teachers themselves
like they just teach what they're told
to teach okay but what can they teach
they can only teach what's put in the
curriculum by who by the governor
so should you get help to buy it's up to
you now would I
nope you know I've seen it's time